momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por eso nos acompaña en nuestro
estudio la periodista daniela blandón
daniela si no es la única gran potencia
que aparece resistió a la crisis
económica cómo es eso hola andrés muy
buenas noches miren su producto interno
bruto avanzó en 23 por ciento en 2020 y
aunque fue el aumento más bajo desde
1976 probablemente lo convierte en el
único país o la única potencia que
cuente con la suerte de crecer en medio
de la pandemia el resultado lo atribuyen
las autoridades a la gran demanda
internacional de productos relativos a
la pandemia y a las políticas de
estímulo económico por ejemplo las
fábricas de reabrieron relativamente
temprano mientras que el resto del mundo
permanecía casi paralizado escuchamos
con nuestra economía ha tenido logros
extraordinarios en un año sin
precedentes un resultado que satisfecho
a nuestra gente llamó la atención del
mundo y podrá pasar a la historia
daniela y las empresas de mariscos en
reinounido protestan contra el break
city porque varios camioneros de
empresas de mariscos británicas delfín
frente al parlament o quejándose de que
el break si te está asfixiando sus
negocios y se parquearon frente a
downing street- que es la sede del
primer ministro boris johnson desde que
entró en vigencia la salida del reino
unido- de la unión europea el primero de
enero ha aumentado drásticamente la
burocracia en las fronteras lo curioso
es que los pescadores británicos
y una van para recuperar el control de
sus aguas pero ahora se están viendo
afectados porque han encontrado más
barreras para exportar y es que la mayor
parte del pescado y el marisco
británicos se va para el exterior
tenemos que cargar un día antes de lo
normal por el papeleo las montañas de
papeles que tenemos que llevar en el
camión desde las declaraciones de aduana
hasta los certificados sanitarios
simplemente no es posible los costos
involucrados son astronómicos siempre
supimos que iba a haber problemas pero
nunca prevemos lo que tenemos frente a
nosotros en este momento
cabe recordar a andrés que fue
justamente la pesca la que más enredo en
las negociaciones del acuerdo comercial
post exit daniela colombia-brasil dieron
a conocer cómo le fue a su economía en
el mes de noviembre si andrés en
comencemos con brasil la actividad
económica cayó 0.83 por ciento en
noviembre de 2020 frente a un año atrás
la buena noticia en este caso es que
acumula siete meses de seguidos de
excepción si se compara frente a los
meses anteriores
pues mire este índice de actividad
económica que por lo general es mensual
permite conocer cómo se está comportando
la economía de un país previo a la
publicación oficial del pib que es
trimestral en colombia' ese índice bajo
3 39% en noviembre y en perú lo hizo en
281 cuando en el peor momento de la
pandemia en este último país había
retrocedido más del 40 por ciento la
mayoría de países coinciden en que los
sectores que han resultado más azotados
con esta crisis han sido evidentemente
los alojamientos y los restaurantes
y daniela en europa se están recuperando
o se está recuperando el empleo cómo es
eso
eurostat que es la oficina de
estadísticas de la unión europea publicó
un informe sobre empleos en el cuarto en
el tercer trimestre del año pasado dice
que la población ocupada de entre 20 y
64 años subió al 72 4% en los 27 países
del bloque comunitario sin embargo no
alcanza todavía los niveles pre
pandémicos que eran del 73 por ciento
una de las conclusiones del informe es
que los jóvenes son a los que más les ha
costado recuperar sus empleos el grupo
de personas de entre 55 y 64 años fue el
único de hecho que incorporó más plazas
de trabajo en el tercer trimestre de
2020 frente a un año atrás
daniela indicadores de la jornada eeuu
no operó por ser día festivo pero
solucionen las otras bolsas por ejemplo
las bolsas de asia reaccionaron mixtas a
las buenas noticias provenientes de
china las bolsas europeas y se dejaron
contagiar del optimismo chino y cerraron
ganancias casi todas con excepción de
londres y en américa latina brasil subió
impulsada por el inicio de la vacunación
y daniela que no tienen las cifras del
día si los casi seis mil millones de
dólares en remesas que recibió el
salvador en 2020 con un incremento del
4,8 por ciento frente a 2019 los envíos
que provienen principalmente de eeuu
comenzaron a crecer en el tercer
trimestre después de haber dejado o
haber bajado drásticamente en meses
anteriores por el gran impacto de la
pandemia
daniela muchas gracias por traernos la
información de la economía aquí en
france 24 y ustedes gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]